hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop now I have
a few gifts that I didn't realize that I
had because I had been getting them for
giving gifts to other people so I got
Punk suede ankle boots plus three
sentiment for every four of a kind or
more affection token match for the
remainder of the day that's handy handy
could it be boink heart necklace drops a
passion level back to zero and gives
plus 2% of total affection gold for each
passionate save long what oh okay I get
that could be good
consume all passion tokens on the grid
yeah yeah it is so you put these back on
here and then you use them on a date but
I don't know who I want to take on a
date with yeah like I go I don't like
Audrey but oddly enough I'm pretty close
to taking her back home with me I don't
know if that would be a good thing or a
bad thing at this point I don't even
know if I wanted get to that point
because it would be inappropriate the
steam version to this game is actually
censored compared to other versions of
this game oh that's right I needs to be
at night before I do that so yeah Nicki
Nicki was super shy Nicki was like
anti-social but she was adorable with
her blue hair and whatever eye color she
had on her eyes and everything else
about her so we're gonna talk about now
you like a retro consult because you're
a gamer that's right your game my
collection is missing this but I want to
see if you remember something
[Music]
Nicki I'll tell you oh I remember the
last time we conversed
said did winter was the one exactly I am
about something we talked about before
oh babe belch bees bees that's right
bees that's not a boring color that
could be the greatest color ever you're
awesome I'll take your question
generally an optimistic or pessimistic
person I'm an optimist pretty much for
my own sanity I try to think positively
I should have known okay fine whatever
you live in your crazy world that you
are in
Tiffany was the schoolgirl right not
really my type at least she's probably
buddy
bubbly buddy but she buddy she's my
buddy what bros sure does doesn't it how
would you like a twirly baton are you CX
oh I can't afford dammit I'm so poor
graduation cap getting it a little early
being a little premature here but I
guess that's time just setting the pace
for your expectations later no tokens
will be consumed as a result of a date
gift being used for the remainder of the
date you'll still get benefits but the
tokens will remain that's cool no I'm
gonna be able to actually use that I
don't get enough sentiment as it is when
these things talk to you breathe [ __ ]
color no you what if I not Oh hobby and
fave hang out okay
[Music]
when's my birthday oh well let me tell
you Tiffany I know exactly December 22nd
because you and me we have a special
connection you I knew that somehow when
I got you that insensitive president now
time to Doug Dyke or I could go Audrey
it's under your Eiko at this point let
me just let me just I don't have a coin
let me flip I'm gonna flip my phone so
if it's heads I get go with all Ike oh
[ __ ] well it was heads okay yes I choose
Ike oh well destiny has spoken
Ike oh it is hyukoh I hope I'm even
pronouncing her name right but at this
point it doesn't matter I'm so
incredibly desperate that I'll literally
do anything for love oh you're not like
that sorry I didn't mean to I thought we
were on the the super heart bar I could
have sworn that we were closer than that
right rice balls rice balls rice balls
is our next gift rice balls I've been
wondering something
longest relationship you've ever had are
you asking me this or did you ask me
this lucky if I can keep it together for
two weeks yes I do don't I I sure do I
can't wait to impress you with my charm
and candy crush skills oh you know the
way they're drawn anime kind of hard to
tell which one is from where I wouldn't
even known that like that other girl was
latina like she looked like every other
anime girl ever racist sorry miss
masters degree in mathematics I didn't
know
[Music]
really yeah I know I'm sorry it's not
that time for that date to happen yet
when i ban you from ever dating me again
it sure is
belli maple leaf here I picked up the
sleep off the ground no actually I paid
$800 for lace oh god my collection was
missing my body choice and my money back
[Music]
good it's great it's the best really
good deeply Spurs oh no I worship the
great love goddess it's probably clear
where I stand
okay good glad you did he's just
completely disagree with me
[Applause]
yeah well I would look at her but yes I
look right into her eyes yeah I know
are you suggesting that something's
gonna happen
oh hey handsome I really enjoyed our
date here's a preview of what I might
just have in store for you all of it
holy crap I thought the steam version
was censored what the hell is happening
there oh don't look kids don't look Oh
God put it away put it away I can't put
it away
swap put it away Santa put it away okay
anyway Lois might have it so hot in here
get harder the more dates you go on so
I've opened mine always learning I've
never heard an answer like that before
you haven't heard [ __ ] lately so
anyway time to talk to the mega [ __ ] no
not Times Doug's I want to talk to kyon
no Tiffani I'm talking to Tiffany
because I've given Tiffany a lot of
gifts so my honey will go up higher when
I talk to her I love big honey's
oh my god I could kiss you please do
you're not like dating anybody else
right now are you my favorite thing to
do exactly exactly like a cheerleader 20
you're 20 I remember yeah I sure did
I sure did I sure did okay whatever can
I talk to
[Music]
[Applause]
good to see you let's see I don't
remember dad cool that's great honey I
like that height that Heights the most
interesting height in the world oh gosh
you're pretty
need help holding up your boobs last
name age weight and hobby how did your
last relationship end I think I remember
this we sorta grew a pardonable regions
sounds like it was for the best though
yep it sure was okay I'm gonna quiz you
remember the level of school I've
completed right didn't you drop out your
drop out right second I wasn't sure you
were gonna get it I got it I sure did
okay thanks for all the hoodie points
now I gotta go to the real date oh boy
you know I will it's the picture she
sent me was any indication this is gonna
be awkward for everyone watching I have
26 year old fears old lady 26 I'm 26
gosh ah what do you like I think she
likes sexuality yeah sexuality okay hey
you want a sexuality little eyes person
that's me that's a whole lot of me I'm a
big honking man I'm a hunky hunk go on
it
you ready wait shouldn't can I give her
a drink I think I might be able to give
her a drink yeah yeah I think so
well Jesus I'm not mr. moneybags here we
have a favorite drink sake of course
she's Japanese racist God okay cool
does that do anything for me on the date
I have no idea all right let's go fourth
day I will remember that also I'll
remember your wait occupation and
favorite season are you ready for the
date of your life oh gosh I only have
three hundred four dollars to my name
and when leaves cost eight hundred
that's not a lot in this economy maybe
they're in like yeah sure let's do that
you mean like this one that I'm playing
right now
[Music]
oh yes very hard I'm losing points too
quickly never baby holy crap this is
no no no I'm baby oh okay I think I'm
going to Oh God blurted Jesus oh that's
silly oh wow oh boy get it out of here
ah I feel dirty I feel every type of
dirty oh god I'm sweating it took me
forever to find my bra this morning
wearing it that's so awkward Jesus oh
man I'm gonna have to like cut out the
whole part good well I'm gonna shut up
I'm gonna replace all the sounds of
pleasure from the crushing of candy with
like family-friendly noises this is
gonna make it even weirder oh my god
alright I guess I accomplished my
mission I have made it with a woman to
inform the men who I'm glad that I could
make everyone so unbelievably
uncomfortable for the past five minutes
thank you everybody so much for watching
I don't know how much more of huniepop
I'll play I mean it's a fun game I will
admit it's a fun game but that is so
regard am Nicholas that it's just
amazing so there's probably other
secrets in this game but I think as far
as my playthrough goes I'm done
but you guys let me know if you for some
reason want to see more so thank you
everybody so much for watching write in
the comments what you think of this game
what you thought of how uncomfortable
were you during that whole part so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you really do want to see more let me
know because I don't think I'm gonna
play
much more than this thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]